The Studio Wrap really is a game changer for us.
It's a new way to look at footwear.
We went after two performance needs for the shoe.
One was solve the hygiene problem and the other was to give her traction.
The foot is the most important part.
The foot is what's engaged in the ground...
...and it's what starts the whole kinetic chain reaction when she's training.
The first inspiration really came from taking a barre class.
Barre is based around the idea of yoga, Pilates...
...and with a little bit of ballet influence mixed in.
I bought a load of all kinds of stretchy material and started wrapping my feet.
I'm playing with different shapes about what felt good on the foot...
...when you moved in different positions.
We're gonna make her foot look beautiful,...
...give her every performance need that she could ever want...
...but not take away that Zen feeling that barefoot experience can give her.
I wanted her to have a product that not only worked for her...
...but she wanted to come on a workout that she felt great...
...like she started her day.